a tech industry battle is taking shape
over the metaverse
what is the metaverse a metaverse in the
metaverse
the metaverse will be the successor to
the mobile internet a metaverse is
essentially a massive virtual world it
can be accessed in real time by millions
of people using avatars the concept is
rooted in science fiction movies like
ready player one
a whole virtual universe
but now it's playing out in the real
world facebook just changed its name to
meta to better reflect its expansion
into the metaverse and it joins
companies like roblox epic games and
microsoft and planning to spend billions
to be at the forefront of building out
these virtual realms
i think we're
still in the beginning stages of this
and so a lot of what's happening is
still just competition if you will
between the companies to like establish
themselves in the metaverse but how
exactly will the metaverse work and why
do tech giants see it as the next
evolution of the internet
for the metaverse it is a convergence of
physical and digital almost like your
your digital lifestyle catching up to
your physical lifestyle in some ways
kathy hackl is the chief metaverse
officer and ceo of the future
intelligence group a consulting company
that provides strategic insight for
companies navigating the metaverse space
it is enabled by many different
technologies like augmented reality
virtual reality blockchain obviously
nfts play a big part there ai 5g cloud
computing so it's not just about one
technology it's not just one thing for
now most metaverse virtual spaces will
look more like the inside of a video
game than real life and some big tech
executives envision the metaverse as an
interoperable open platform this means
no one company or organization will own
it and avatars will be able to move
freely between metaverse virtual spaces
there's all these different platforms
and the question is
sort of how do you connect all those and
whether it's going to be possible to
jump from you know you have your avatar
on roblox can you you know somehow cross
through and get to facebook through that
are the platforms going to be connected
in some ways the metaverse is already
here immersive games like fortnite and
gaming platforms like roblox include
metaverse like elements where gamers can
use avatars to play games and attend
events or use digital currency to buy
products roblox and fortnite so they
kind of
i guess someone say have a leg up
already because they already have these
huge user bases and they have the
platform developed you know they're not
building something from scratch and so i
think that's a huge advantage for them
so they're mostly i think just focused
on developing these in-app experiences
or these games for instance roblox
recently unveiled what will be a huge
overhaul for its avatar system allowing
players to be more lifelike and
customizable our vision goes well beyond
play we're imagining a place where
people learn together where people work
together meanwhile epic games which owns
fortnite announced it raised one billion
dollars in funding to support its vision
for the metaverse
they recently made announcements that
they're gonna start to look at
potentially working with blockchain
developers so that in itself is a big
signal of some level of openness
facebook's name change reflects its
ambition of being a big player in the
metaverse race we believe the metaverse
will be the successor to the mobile
internet
we'll be able to feel present like we're
right there with people no matter how
far apart we actually are the company
which already owns oculus vr is spending
billions on other vr company
acquisitions and hardware development
and it plans to create 10 000 jobs in
the european union over the next five
years to build the virtual space
we expect to invest many billions of
dollars for years to come before the
metaverse reaches scale the company's
expansion into the metaverse comes amid
intense criticism over revelations in
the wall street journal facebook file
series which showed the company knows
its platforms are riddled with flaws
that cause harm ceo mark zuckerberg has
said that the criticism paints a false
picture of the company he co-founded it
would be in the best interest of the
company to kind of make sure that they
maybe distance themselves from you know
the facebook app and some of the things
that have come to light zuckerberg says
the name change reflects the company's
goals to move beyond social media apps
building our social media apps will
always be an important focus for us
but right now our brand is so tightly
linked to one product that it can't
possibly represent everything that we're
doing today let alone in the future
other companies like microsoft are
focusing on strategic game company
acquisitions that could give them a
foothold in the metaverse space the
company already has a history in the
gaming world it created the popular
video game console xbox they
closed like a 7.5 billion dollar deal on
the video game company zenimax media
earlier this year and they also were
previously in talks to buy discord and
in march microsoft announced its new
microsoft mesh platform which enables
shared experiences on any device through
mixed reality applications
accelerated interest in the metaverse
was fueled in part by the pandemic while
stuck inside
people spent more time online roblox
reported 42.1 million daily active users
in q1 of 2021 a 78 increase from the
same time the previous year
so the pandemic really kind of set us
forward a couple years in people
understanding the convergence of digital
and physical right and really for us to
really think about the future of the
internet what comes next for now the
shared ambitions of these giant
corporations are setting the stage for
high-stakes race to create this digital
world the metaverse is going to impact
every vertical in every industry in some
way right that's going to impact the way
we socialize the way we work the way we
have fun
so it is going to touch you know almost
every aspect of our lives